so are you dreading the return or
exchange process now that you've
received all your lovely holiday gifts
right the crowded customer service desk
the confusion in the store policies well
in today's and on your side our money
saving expert has eight steps to make
that return and exchange hassle free
pay attention to deadlines most major
retailers offer flexible return policies
Walmart has returns through January 31st
but Apple Cuts returns off as of January
8th Andrea Warwick says give your return
some thought before rushing to exchange
a gift request merchandise credit and
cash in on that merchandise credit get
more Bang from your Exchange Dollars by
shopping sales clearance rack and
looking for coupon codes you can go to a
site like couponfollow.com they organize
coupon codes by store name every time
you make an exchange turn it into cash
back take a picture of it using a
cashback app like fetch rewards earning
points toward free gift cards to a
variety of merchants you may have to pay
a restocking fee for some returns this
is typically applied to an Electronics
or an appliance so hold on to all the
packaging and try to negotiate the fee
if the item was faulty keep your
receipts organized if you make a return
without a receipt you might not get the
actual value of the gift the person who
gave it to you spent so just make sure
you hold on to those gift receipts tape
them to the packages that's a great way
to avoid losing them leverage your
credit cards purchase protection if you
bought an item you can't return because
you missed the deadline or a missing
packaging check your credit card's
purchase protection policy call your
credit card issuer see what the return
protection policy is some may extend the
amount of time you have to make the
return you'll just have to do it through
the credit card company
all right and the eighth tip check your
statements for returns use an app like
mint to track the Returns on your debit
and credit cards it alerts you when a
return is posted to your account